done a real lucky gig I was asked by a
event coordinator to do a gig for their
client and would I meet their client
first and would I Caravan behind her to
the car the client's house so I said
okay and I followed her and uh we went
up to malibo and she goes this is
Barbara and this is Richard no not
Barbara strian exactly are you kidding
me Barbara strian she was my first big
big gig that I did and it was her Sons
bar mitzvah for uh Jason gold the son of
Elliot and and Barbara and she put on
this in she was the nicest person
everyone said afterwards oh God yeah
she's such a and all this kind of
stuff she couldn't have been nice if you
show up and do your job she treated you
like gold